[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con en france 24
mi nombre es liliana valència el coach
19 puede dejar serias consecuencias en
algunos pacientes por ejemplo uno de
cada diez contagiados han presentado
secuelas como trombosis problemas
cardíacos alteraciones del sueño pérdida
del cabello depresión o tos aguda y
hasta 205 síntomas diferentes que han
sido reportados por personas recuperadas
esto según una investigación del equipo
neurocientífico del colegio
universitario de londres para hablar
sobre el síndrome post coidh está con
nosotros el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
médico infectólogo y asesor científico
de france24 bienvenido doctor pérez
nuevamente cuéntenos a qué se debe que
el organismo no se recupere del todo
siga presentando síntomas y desarrolle
este llamado síndrome post coito
liviana la mayoría de pacientes se van a
recuperar completamente de covite en
general en las personas que tienen
infección mucho más severa que ha
requerido cuidado crítico
hospitalización suplencia de oxígeno
estas personas tenía una inflamación muy
grande de su cuerpo y eso hace que su
recuperación sea lenta y en algunos
pacientes persistan los síntomas al
parecer hay una relación entre la
gravedad del coi y la persistencia de
síntomas en tiempo que lo que llamamos
síndrome post code
doctor hagamos diferencia entre el
síndrome post koi del cual ya venimos
hablando y otros síntomas post contagio
tienen alguna relación o como los
podemos diferenciar
hay dos situaciones una es el cover
prolongado que es la persistencia de los
síntomas por las cuales el paciente
ingresa por ejemplo la fatiga los
dolores articulares la dificultad para
respirar y hay otro momento que son las
secuelas las secuelas es cuando por
ejemplo había un daño pulmonar porque ha
requerido ventilación mecánica el
paciente tiene su pulmón afectado
completamente y requiere oxígeno o tiene
alguna alteración neurológica porque es
un evento vascular esto ya establece es
una secuela después del coach que es
diferente a la persistencia de los
síntomas en el coi
ambas son igualmente preocupantes al ver
de que en rehabilitación y tratamiento y
ambas están descritas
después de estos picos epidémicos en los
enfermos del cómic sobre todo en los que
han estado hospitalizados doctor
cuéntenos cuáles son esas similitudes o
diferencias entre los diferentes
síntomas que presenta el síndrome de
posco y vemos que ciertos pacientes unos
son los síntomas más relacionados con el
cansancio o fatiga caída del cabello
pero también otros presentan diferentes
síntomas completamente opuestos que
tienen que ver con otras condiciones son
siempre lo mismo síntomas o qué tan
diferentes son entre ellos
hay variaciones en general el síndrome
post kobe por ejemplo en hay algún
segmento que es mucho más importante en
mujeres en donde hay la persistencia
este dolor articular de estos síntomas
de fatiga hay otras cosas que se han
relacionaron que no directamente están
con alcohol como puede ser disparar
algunas enfermedades autoinmunes como
artritis enfermedades del colágeno o
pueden haber otros síntomas sobre todo
los más especiales son los trastornos de
ansiedad neuropsiquiátricos y
emocionales que derivan uno de los
cambios neurológicos por la enfermedad
después de la inflamación y dos también
del temor y de la ansiedad que genera la
soledad eliminen se de muerte estar
hospitalizado en una unidad el cuadro
crítico que llevan a un gran
conglomerado es decir estamos ante una
etiología compleja y si poco sabemos de
código de bosco de que estamos hasta
ahora aprendida hablemos un poco más de
ese tema doctor porque llama la atención
que reportes de personas muestren que
padecieron el coi 19 y posteriormente
presentan cuadros de depresión incluso
de disfunción cognitiva según los
reportes en la fase
qué nos puede contar usted de esto ya
nos venía explicando pero profundizamos
un poco
durante el convite hay un periodo de
inflamación un periodo donde el cuerpo
trata de reaccionar y lo hace una forma
desmedida por decirlo de alguna forma y
esa inflamación no solamente afecta a
los pulmones nos afecta neurológicamente
nos afecta a nivel de todos los órganos
de la economía de todos los grandes es
de normal el cerebro es muy sensible a
estos cambios inflamatorios y se ha
visto en estos pacientes pérdida de la
memoria alteraciones cognitivas porque
la inflamación no es solamente pulmonar
sino de todo el órgano y el cerebro se
ve afectado si hemos visto que los
pacientes después de recuperarse de cody
en alteraciones de lógicas psiquiátricas
y por eso es importante la
rehabilitación temprana gracias por
ampliarlo sobre esta información doctor
carlos eduardo pérez médico infectólogo
y acceso científico de france 24 y 23
gracias por estar con nosotros continúen
con más en france24 punto com
[Música]